my boyfriend tried to educate me on the
way over about some I don't know some
guy who said something insulting to
female sports announcer Cam Newton
pretty popular quarterback said he got a
question from a beat reporter that works
for the his team and asked him something
about our wide receivers route running
and he said it's surprising that a
girl's asking about route running or
something like that he got a lot of
about it right now I got a drop from a
sponsor it's also going on further is
that all he said I'm it's surprising
that a girl I believe so and then they I
heard that they went further into it off
off the record a little bit and he was
rude is what she said oh okay okay we
really expect you know the football the
quarterback to be the height of you know
politeness and social etiquette and okay
Asian has said this and I think that
these there are some incredible women
who are sports announcers so I'm told by
the boyfriend and I think it's sexy to
be a knowledgeable woman in sports
however we now prosecute everybody for
everything and the reason we do that is
there's too much media everybody's got a
microphone and everyone's on Twitter so
now the stuff the dumb stuff people
would have said another era that would
have just gone off into the ether now it
is just it's a news story do you think
it's that or is it I'm sure it is that
but isn't it also that we're examining
behavior on a much more intense scale
than we've ever done before and we see
things that we don't like and we're
highlighting those things in a much more
aggressive way than we've ever done
before it's almost like there's
accelerating social evolution that's
going on right now and along the way
you're getting a lot of bumps and a lot
of weird stuff that's happening a lot of
social justice warrior stuff and then
you've got a lot of alt-right stuff on
the other side and they're battling it
out with each other and it's almost like
these intense extremes on this new
landscape and people are jockeying for
positioning on this new cultural
standard playing field well I think
what's happened is that now everyone has
a microphone mm-hmm so everyone's on
Twitter everyone can make a tweet that
put out a tweet that gets tweeted and
retweeted to four
million people and so people are looking
to have standing and they're doing it by
putting up their opinions and they also
when you're saying this about these
tribes they do it to signal look I'm
part of this tribe I'm a social justice
warrior I'm on the right I'm an tyfa and
so I think that that's a big part of it
so they're looking for criminal behavior
socially criminal behavior and whereas
you know this guy I mean do I really
expect every quarterback to have the
most PC views no and okay he's gonna
lose his sponsorship when he says
something like this but you know if you
open the quarterback can you're gonna
see quarterback stuff in there and it's
not you know the Emily Post well first
of all with quarterbacks and with any
football players you're dealing with
head trauma you are a 100% dealing with
head trauma yeah there is a extremely
high likelihood that all those guys on
the playing field are have erratic
behavior due to the fact their heads
been smashed a hundred and fifty
times a year since they were a kid and
that is just a fact there's no getting
around that
yeah and I actually I really appreciate
that we're starting to see people look
at that and bring that out so parents
know you know would you want your son to
play football or to play some other
sport yeah I mean look I have kids and I
wouldn't want my kids to fight even
though I'm a commentator and fighting
right I just think like God if you
really want to do it
I mean I'll support them in anything
they really want to do but I would tell
them look it's just the upside and the
downside like if you can get out like
some guys get out like Floyd Mayweather
I mean he's just a brilliant tactician
and incredibly good defensively and he
got out relatively unscathed but you
really won't know how unscathed until
10-15 years from now when you see him
struggling with his words right right
it's just not worth it your life is life
is short but it's long if you're
up oh absolutely and you see that from
these guys I read some story about that
the other day I'm trying to think who is
the guy so so sad and this thing about
it showing up much later where you get
terribly mental it's mentally ill people
they make those trade-offs where they
think okay well I can get money and fame
this way and it's quick and everything
like that but they don't really realize
what the long-term
consequences will be yeah well I think a
lot of people in the God in the football
and even people that got into fighting
they didn't they didn't know as much
back then when they first entered this
or journey yeah you know especially
football I mean football I mean we
really that there was no conversation
about that think about like the OJ trial
you know I've been kind of on this OJ
kick lately because I started watching
that a Cuba Gooding jr. series well yes
sort of you know reenacts right and it's
really kind of freaking me out it's
bringing back the memories of the 90s
and what what it was like when that when
that thing went down I was with my
girlfriend at the time and we were
sitting in front of the television
holding hands and you know like waiting
for the verdict and when when they said
not guilty she threw her hands on her
face like she had just seen a horrible
car accident she was like oh my god oh
my god she kept saying oh my god oh my
god oh my god and now today they're
saying the the the the very doctor that
was working with OJ said if they were
going to do that case again today they
would absolutely bring up CTE yeah I
think you're right about that absolutely
and and there's so many football players
who got in just not knowing who will
come out like that I think within a
number of years yeah that was only 20
years ago 23 years ago so 23 years ago
nobody thought about brain trauma you
came to football which is just that's
impossible now these guys are
debilitated there's a whole bunch of
different lawsuits they're going on
right now with the NFL and you're seeing
these older players I mean they have
unreal sports at Bryant Gumbel and
they're sitting there and they're
shaking and they can't control
themselves you know like Wow well this
is this is unheard of twenty years ago
thirty years ago we never thought of
this this is never in the public
discourse yeah and I suspect if you go
back and look at those tapes sort of
forensic ly that you'll see that kind of
thing the shaking and and also that if
you look at to take a look at over
football players how many people have
these these diseases and mental illness
that's related to this head trauma
yeah I'm sure quite a bit but mean this
football player guy that we're talking
about Cam Newton you know what the only
thing that's wrong with I mean it's not
even wrong
he's trying to get sponsors that's the
whole deal yeah and if you're whatever
coca-cola or whatever the company is you
don't want someone representing you that
does something like that no and so it's
sort of normal yeah
well it's normal that they say okay
we're dumping you and it's normal that
he would say it but what's always funny
is that these these companies they
profess surprise when it's like really
you know you thought that this person
was gonna be this sort of curtailed
reined in person it's like with Kathy
Griffin oh you just figured out that she
says events of things yeah that was a
surprise to you well it wasn't I mean
with with her was just like so poorly
thought out it's like what do you what
is the message there you're holding up a
bloody head like Jesus Christ yeah I
mean if you want to hold up the bloody
head of some murderous dictator who's
you know killed a bunch of people then I
kind of understand but even then like
what what is a you Isis like what's this
message right well I think she didn't
think it out and it was just okay
outraged trying to be shocked he's
trying to be shocking and then the sort
of the fake apology and then okay take
it back it was the fake apology and then
it was like he's a bully and he broke me
and like come on like this playing the
victim card yeah your comedian yeah you
know and I know comedians have like that
then you know what someone's gonna
heckle you on and so you have stuff
ready for that and this thing like where
she saw like me you know my career is
over I don't have a career now it's like
alright just take a couple months off
you'll be fun Yeah right people forget
there's some new outrage well there's
always gonna be this always has some new
crazy thing and it's also gonna
be a bunch of people that are probably
excited that you did that too yeah
they'll calm down after a while it won't
be in the news anymore and yeah it's
just we live in a time where everything
is hyper examined yeah it is and and so
that's standard and that's why I think
we have to be more lenient with people
this idea that you say something awful
and then you're excommunicated you lose
your job you're gonna be living in a
dumpster this is really wrong we need to
understand that to be human is to be an
we're all we all say
shitty things to people and I try to
recognize my ashiness and
apologize when I've been awful and make
if sometimes you have to put some money
into making good it's it's what the
situation calls for
[Applause]
[Music]